super positive day so pumped oh man this
is what I married can't be a meal to
snack ma'am she's crazy but I love her
Bailey go back hotel going back to hotel
hitting things here
alright usual search of the day smoothie
yesterday I did twenty thousand three
hundred and ninety five steps yeah
really alright we decided to get two
coffees and we're supposed to eat
healthy Nina stocked a nice breakfast
for us but I also decided to splurge and
got our usual Egg McMuffin and hash
brown and aninha decided that she wanted
to eat my hat around so I guess I'm
moving it to her and havens having a
bagel yammi yammi okay just got home
super hungry turning hangry it's past I
don't know what time it is it's like two
o'clock almost happening anything except
what i showed you guys are ready so Nina
made some lentils and pork or something
no idea how you get grams protein or
anything I just got to eat something
alright fish weird of you Nina okay so
it's been a while since my last video
it's been a while since at eight we went
the tds I talked my first level six
class for the semester super exciting
Nina led you did well didn't thanks to
Alex he's already yeah it's a good class
though and I had to come home and do
another 3000 steps to hit 20 I know
tiscali I'm smelling I know did you see
the video thing you have a shower I'm
worried because after that Microsoft on
Tuesday I'm they're filming with them
and then Wednesday I'm they're basically
the whole day I'm the plane and then
because of time zone i leave at eight in
the morning and get back at eight at
night our time it's no direct flights
idea took go to Vancouver I'm worried
about keep them the diet especially on
that Wednesday will be like running
around the airport to get my steps and I
think I'm going to maybe buy some
protein powder or something maybe the
last time i went it was so busy the
Microsoft guys happy booked like morning
to evening I had one evening off in this
when I met Jen so it's crazy I may not
be that crazy this time I don't know
because last night I didn't get to talk
to him at all I'm doing at least one
interview with them maybe two more
videos or maybe do it all my sets it's
still kind of unclear but hopefully
figure that out in time I'm excited I'm
excited about the interview I'm kind of
missed as a lot of stuff happening I'm
not really a hungry I'll have a quick
small third of a shake wake up tomorrow
do it all again and then head to Seattle
good morning rushing today I've got to
eat got my usual slowly steps yesterday
was 20,000 471 I've got to go to the
passport office get havens passports we
can go to Disney World in March then hit
the Toronto and salsa we're painting the
ceiling finishing put it in the ceiling
tiles visit a meetings and have to get
off to Microsoft later today to go
interview with them and hopefully stay
I'll be all right at TDS pack my
breakfast doesn't look appetizing
display little bit yelling alex is here
working away we're getting the paint
done on the ceiling you can see there's
a lot of tiles missing and there's some
gross tiles so we got to get it all
fixed up this place is going to be
spanking new sexy anyway it's protein on
got some good steps in can you all today
okay next up finishing off my smoothie
from Nina just my shopping proteins for
the trip and it was hard because most of
the stuff is so high in sugar it's crazy
sugar content crazies like 10 grams of
protein in 19 grams of sugar I'm kidding
so I was very careful I thought
something that happened in like 10 grams
of protein it took me a while to do some
research i work with Sean you get me
some
Senate they got one for like a hundred
dollars at stake it's just massive right
but sugar it's super super bad alex is
doing the the diet and workout regimen
with that he's not on the 30 day
challenge with me Nina but you should be
so I scored a few winners I hope I got
this North Coast Naturals I so protein I
need something I could fit in my
carry-on right so it's only going for a
couple days the problem with the bars
the bars have insane sugar so I found
this protein crunch pumpkin seeds that
I've never tried and that was the best
rate that I could find so I bought three
for the chip and Alex I gotta have one
right now it's still kind of sweet i
love these fun years kept your meals and
snack man all right construction work
happening back to work for me okay
lunchtime chicken breast with dress
salad with apple cider vinegar tomatoes
and spinach and mixed greens in there
excited to dig in having more confidence
chillin with Stephanie Alex ox don't
have the greatest day thank you but he's
been negotiating like a piece for the
well-being of the business well beyond
the business do a good job I feel like
I'm going at the airport and when I have
a new guys kappa that's what we know
then kill everything happens you know
the gonna be made it into my flight the
challenge now is finding some food that
is quasi healthy so super fast to get
through customs 20 minutes but almost
two hours of hoorka me I ended up
homeless Tim Hortons chili so
unfortunately the internet seems to be
down at the moment your sucks because I
usually talk to me now say goodbye all
that stuff before I go but I can't get
on the lot online
mr. baby see you soon so I'm gonna board
in about an hour and started crashing
today so i decided that i would buy a
copy this three-hour time difference i
gained three hours coming here but
really I feel like it's cuz i havent
drinking any water all day long I'm just
doing TDS stuff so I also Harbor water
you know I looked at my fifth at
eighteen thousand six hundred sixty
seven steps honey thirteen hundred plus
more steps to get my hands on
my drink walk around the airport so just
arrived in seattle airport looks exactly
the same wasn't here that long ago watch
two movies on the plane don't member the
first one it was hard to hear a Sicario
something like that the mexican drug one
it's okay but i couldn't really hear it
well and psycho moen was a Martian which
i like it was better than I thought it's
midnight for me 9 p.m. here in Seattle
and I'm off to look for the car that's
going to take me to my hotel and silly
to have a little bit more protein before
Monday well well well certain the
seriously crash ever I almost fell
asleep in the car feel a little nauseous
I think it's just too tired and have a
sudden a while let's find them alive 05
this is interesting there's just a
window that goes right through the
bathroom nice big shower I like it the
groom looking good chibi on yeah nice i
like the setup that's that's pretty cool
ec straight to the bathroom I don't know
what to make of it I like it I think
protein and get ready for bed do some
emails crash wake up tomorrow I like it
says welcome have a car mark on the
screen look at that the little details
matter all right bedtime for me and I
will check in with you guys tomorrow
good morning from seattle hotel room 645
am got about 15 minutes ago excited for
the day starting off with this is not
coffee this is my protein shake going to
check in on the youtube channel
responder comments check up in the next
videos and then explore seattle before
how am I go do my interview with
microsoft
I'm excited all right just past 9am had
a nice quick run did some work at a
shower but it go explore seattle and
find some food it's of course raining in
Seattle but I don't mind because its way
warmer than Toronto there's no snow and
I'm heading off to a pike place to find
the very first ever starbucks I don't
excited to have a coffee and get some
food so I made a pit stop at features
just famous for their cheese then you
see these huge bats and cheese with a
mix in it there and cooking and the
other one and it smells so good sorry
I'm trying they're totally super
unhealthy mac and cheese this little
thing cost me six bucks so try it
sigo it is
I'm feeling really good that was new the
best mac and cheese I've ever had in my
life and now we're coming up to the
first starbucks interesting fact the the
house one is called pike because this
place is called Pike Place and so they
kept that name and for all of their
house blank of office called pipe in at
the original location here they have the
same logo they haven't changed it this
is the original logo when the bars Tony
collects like Starbucks cups and we
collect them everywhere we go on trips
official here's what we're going to find
is really good I like being in a
historic place I feel like I'm going to
buy a hawk Adair County tomb and just
keep it on my desk smell the coffee
beans you're lining up this place big
fence of Howard Schultz one of my face
is heroes reminds with that a little bit
of peace home walking back to the hotel
super excited book is done at least the
first draft it's off to the publisher
it's an overwhelmingly exciting feeling
to know that it's it's happening it's
out of my hands it's finally over I know
there's gonna be some fights not edit
and what's going to stay in and there's
still a lot more work ahead but to be in
the first start box and such a historic
place and I hope that my book can have
just as historic and impact on the world
just I don't know it's over it's
overwhelmingly exciting yeah super
positive day so pumped bought a bunch of
stuff going back to hotel hitting things
here shower having anything just buzzed
on starbucks coffee and I got to get
ready for my interview with microsoft
okay haven't really had lunch yet which
is not super healthy not even really
hungry but I got to go to my interview
soon so I'm gonna have some more these
pumpkin seed things and maybe find
something else along the way all right
I'm off I did a little bit of running
practice what I was going to talk about
did some pushups had a shower and ready
to go rock the interview this is where
we're filming rework the platform for
creators
I guess all right come in the green I'm
waiting for my session to start got some
lunch chicken Caesar salad from the
catering company and soaps in the back
look at that cookie ah Justin on the
side i love it okay to make up time Nina
always get super excited i'll make up
high because i never let her put makeup
on me except for one single halloween so
she's always exciting life to go to
makeup ok we go yes alright then had a
lot of fun wasn't out the film because
it's exclusive content but it was really
good did a couple takes got some good
points at everybody's super motivated
and i'm excited to see the final product
i'm heading back to hotel gonna meet jen
has some dinner see what i can find and
then make some youtube videos with her
i'm excited it's a good day while i wait
for jen before dinner gonna have a
little bit of more protein crunch
pumpkin seeds because i'm getting hungry
this is jen you guys know jen and next
up this is only for foods it's cameron
look for food so the next thing on the
food list is the alcohol which has no
protein but then we're gonna go find a
strong look at I've alcohol for
Stephanie Rick especially interesting
and I'm gonna find a restaurant and find
equal okay we're at a place that has a
thousand spirits
we're going to see we need us I'm
putting the candle in my pic super dark
can you see me not really no
I'm going to break this anyway this is
the insane dinner oh you can't see
anything it's a burger an insane burger
that smells really good although you can
kind of see it you can't really see it
I'm breaking the diet but I think we're
gonna be okay yeah it's working so much
of protein lots of protein okay it's
almost three in the morning my time
burning out just got back from filming
videos and having a good chat with jen i
still need to have 48 grams of protein
to hit my daily goal so i got to have
some protein shake go to bed not pack go
to bed and then wake up early tomorrow
morning get on the cab and start the
trek home good morning basically i'm
traveling all day long I gotta catch a
flight are eight in the morning and I'm
gonna be back home at eight or nine at
night something like that is crazy gonna
have a protein shake hopefully not eat
too much crap at the airport looking
forward to see my wife eating healthy
again yeah
all right back in Toronto excited it's
snowing outside little bit noshes
probably cuz I've been slept well but
excited to see Nina and get back home
all right
that's fine Anna I don't see you
anywhere where is Nina
I have the message her she's not here so
she messaged me have I arrived yes where
is she she's taking a lock down the
right I'm here I gotta go find her this
is ridiculous I gotta find her this is
the second time now in the last three
visits that I about it yeah come out
there's no Nina I was here you know why
because you see those lists of fights
that wasn't my plight none of my place
on there yeah i'm typing can say right
here well i don't know anyone here i
miss my wife I mean she's crazy I don't
love her we're gonna go now we're gonna
go okay came home and I am 62 grams of
protein away from my goal so luckily
Nina made this amazing yummy salad for
me chicken and pomegranate and and salad
I'm excited Thank You Nina we love you
back in Toronto feeling good back on my
regular routine super excited certain
day with my smoothie and egg and lentils
ready to start my day didn't realize it
but it's 420 and I haven't really eaten
my lunch because you go when children
fulfilling then I start eating forgot
the film so lunch is chicken and salad
and more pomegranates underneath with
some apple cider vinegar i'm off to
mastermind tonight and it gets catered
and i don't know what the meal is so i
might bring a can of tuna or something
with me just in case so far so good
eating healthy so i have a meeting with
my master my group downtown today and
i'm way behind on my steps six thousand
steps I'm supposed to be at 20 by the
end of the day and I'm worried I'm not
gonna hit it so instead of driving down
and this insane cold I am bundling up
I'm gonna take the subway and walk just
a meeting here for the meeting dinner
dinner is salad whatever that is Veggie
make this is esther frost their friend
Victor fraud and some rice on the end
this is louie from last minute training
hey Jeremy mentor network is
day in the life of Evan this is the
30-day his tea vodka me challenge all
right welcome to day 12 first up as
usual proofing drink all right it's
breakfast time and the usual lentils an
egg Jay rise in the house brought me
grande caramel macchiato era la Giada to
all right next up is came of tuna what
can we went to work out fast I totally
forgot to bring the GoPro and film a
time-lapse because I haven't been for a
while and anyway just let my mind so
came back I need to catch up on some
protein is having a shower and I'm
really thirsty so having a quick drink
visiting with 20 programs and winnie
dinner and head to salsa ebony tonight
where I'm teaching a lesson and djing
should be fun all right hand a nice
shower get ready to go to salsa party
tonight Nina's maid-sama me food what
are we eating your big salmon this is
the salmon and what's this let's melon
on top me alright day 13 Saturday
morning start the day another protein
drink Tina's doing it too we're explore
still have to have the Tim Hortons
breakfast so maybe light and how do you
shake it you got it shake shake swirl
swirl circular motion use your
oh man this is what I made your face
doesn't look like you to a happy person
is all right at 10 with my wife her name
is Nina she's special we loved her
breakfast Nina she's having egg and
cheese I'm not have every sausage egg
and cheese to hash browns on the coffee
think of the healthy expect this is why
I thought you can go home for Saturday
Dina's like join up lentils are
breakfast like now I don't want to have
lunch again lunch is over there mommy
look so here we got home Cheers so we
just came back from costco or in the car
and we're trying a new protein powder
lean fit complete green protein 19 grams
of protein per scoop I was on the fence
because the traditional like non-organic
whatever ones are basically almost half
the price at the price and then Nina
insisted that we get this one for this
healthy only bought two of them Nina
cares about her husband and insisted
that we get the more expensive now
natural one if I hold it up you can't
see me anymore Nina is more important in
the protein all right this lunchtime
it's 310 it's a really late lunch Nina
got a little hangry but she's pretty
good though she is wearing a purple top
today she wants the way up to the camera
in a big way there it is do we have over
here this put up with this is my this is
chicken and what's the other one turkey
so which one do you want I don't care
just the chicken breast is this mixed
with the rice cake in there probably the
chicken ok what's the salad there you go
look at the size of this salad it's
intense chicken breast and salad here we
go ok family we had a lot of veggies but
only 25 grams and push me with that
piece of chicken so that's why I'm
feeling a little hungry now so we went
the Loblaws about a quest bar highly
recommended to me by my sister Stephanie
and one of the instructors at EDS so I'm
going to try it out there's an extra 20
grams I still another 60 15 I'll figure
it out later we'll do the numbers I'm
gonna have to have some more weight
Nina's done we're supposed to be doing
karaoke right now remove the pit stop
and we're going to go sing some songs
I'm going to sing some songs and we
going to make the innocence of songs so
we can't get you jumped because that's
not part of the diet ok well the pup was
conceded oh my god I when heated up ok
quest bar ok behind a my protein so I
came home had a I'm about to have some
tuna last up the protein drink already
had a few steps with this brings my
total to 181 grams of protein on the day
just enough it is 955 p.m. we're off to
go watch ride along to drive down the
drink and then head up we're back from
the moving it's 125 am this is the first
day that I've been hungry since we
started this is day 13 while guess
almost day 14 today was the first day
that I felt hungry and
to have enough food i have unsealed i'm
going to bed a little bit hungry as i
was hungry earlier but held off what are
the fifth movie theater is like popcorn
oh man I wanna have some of this it was
the first day that I felt usually it's
hard to finish it's like ten o'clock at
night eleven o'clock every for bad as if
I still need to eat more protein today
was the first day we'll recap that and
I'm I'm a little hungry oh that means
but tomorrow's weigh-in day so right
thank you keep keep your stomach empty
right well wait it tomorrow wake up
we're songs and eat okay here we go with
a 14 and the plea to it is time to do
anyway in me was at first one 22.7
that's meaning so let's see me i started
at 20 6.6 i went to 200 point nine on
day seven and then day 14 is today let's
see so from 200 point nine
195 25 feeling good last 10 pounds
awesome 11 11.1 parents in four days to
14th day we're answered okay okay so
that's good